[Música]
y
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su programa
sobre la actualidad francesa en esta
edición hablaremos de la reciente
restitución de bienes culturales que
hizo el gobierno francés a bening cómo y
por qué se dio este proceso luego el pan
será nuestro centro de atención porque
este alimento sagrado para los franceses
está aumentando de precio la razón el
alza de las materias primas veremos como
panaderos y consumidores están lidiando
con esto y por último los juguetes su
costo para este fin de año podría
haberse impactado por la crisis global
de la cadena de suministro
el 27 de octubre tuvo lugar aquí en el
museo de la que en la ceremonia de
restitución a benin de 26 obras de los
palacios de abomey esas piezas llegaron
a parís en 1892 como botín de guerra del
ejército colonial francés esta
restitución permite de alguna manera
enmendar los errores del pasado pero
también renovar las relaciones con las
ex colonias francesas en áfrica algo que
de manuel marco ha buscado a lo largo de
su mandato estas obras han sido
esperadas durante mucho tiempo
tanto tiempo todos los jóvenes necesitan
apropiarse de la historia de su país
para construir mejor su futuro
para redescubrir el poder a veces los
misterios
y no hay razón para que la juventud
africana no tenga acceso a su patrimonio
en el siguiente reportaje les explicamos
cómo se realizó este proceso de
restitución y la controversia que ha
generado
el 28 de noviembre de 2017 el presidente
francés hizo una declaración solemne
ante un grupo de jóvenes burkineses en
la universidad de cuota
sin duda existe
no puedo aceptar que una gran parte del
patrimonio cultural de varios países
africanos esté en francia
quiero que dentro de cinco años se
cumplan las condiciones para la
restitución temporal o definitiva del
patrimonio africano en áfrica
26 objetos procedentes del reino de tajo
mi actual bening fueron rápidamente
identificados como candidatos para su
restitución conservados y expuestos en
el museo que branly de parís desde 2016
habían sido reclamados por bening país
que no esperaba una respuesta positiva
tan rápidamente
tomó a todos por sorpresa cuando dijo de
acuerdo devuelvo 26 objetos pero no es
porque los devuelva que inmediatamente
vamos a traerlos y ponerlos en cualquier
lado quisimos mantener la calma museo
tarda 10 años pero aquí vamos a tener un
plazo un poco más corto
de hecho en benin las instalaciones del
palacio de abomey no son aptas para el
retorno de estas obras en buenas
condiciones un proyecto de museo se está
ultimando pero todavía no existe
mientras tanto las obras de arte se
conservarán a 100 kilómetros de
distancia en cuida el puerto del que
partieron hacia francia hace 130 años
como sea desde el momento en que
empecemos a devolverle objetos a bening
otros países dirán perfecto ahora porque
solo a venir porque no a gabón a egipto
porque no a china a todo el mundo
tanto a pesar de la controversia y de
los numerosos debates suscitados por
esta decisión del presidente francés el
24 de diciembre de 2020 se adoptó la ley
relativa a la restitución de los bienes
culturales benineses los 26 objetos
fueron expuestos por última vez en
francia en el museo que franklin unos
días antes de su regreso definitivo a
benin a principios de noviembre
mal dicha costa de márfil son varios los
países africanos que ya han formulado
peticiones de restitución a francia lo
cual hace temer a muchos que los museos
comienzan a ser vaciados sin embargo las
colecciones nacionales en francia son
inalienables
el presidente del que bolt y explica
cuáles son las condiciones para que un
objeto pueda ser restituido a su país de
origen
estos objetos fueron adquiridos por
medio de la violencia por medio de la
coacción este es uno de los criterios
que se tuvieron en cuenta para responder
a la solicitud de restitución de bening
que decía que era inadmisible que estos
objetos permanecieran hoy en la
colección nacional de francia cuando
habían sido adquiridos sin el
consentimiento de los propietarios
originales de
la baguette es el símbolo francés por
excelencia pero también es un producto
que sirve de indicador del costo de la
vida diaria el alza de las materias
primas está repercutiendo en su precio
los precios no han cambiado por el
momento pero en esta panadería de monte
el día los clientes esperan un aumento
del precio del pan en las próximas
semanas
resignados no piensan cambiar sus
hábitos
qué podemos hacer tenemos que aceptarlo
no tenemos muchas opciones además cuando
se tiene un buen pan aunque haya que
pagar diez centavos más se pagan o quizá
ahorraremos en otro tipo de productos
pero el pan es una de las cosas
esenciales si estabas al precio o cual
precio uno paga no deja de poner
gasolina la sigue poniendo la causa es
el repentino aumento del precio del
trigo más del 30 por ciento en un año
por tanto la harina es mucho más cara y
aquí representa el 20 por ciento de los
gastos para empezar este panadero se
prepara para aumentar el precio de sus
baguette entre 5 y 10 céntimos solo toma
con el aumento de todas las demás
materias primas ya no podemos asumirlo a
nosotros porque la mantequilla el azúcar
los huevos todo sube un aumento del
precio de las materias primas a que los
panaderos artesanos les cuesta encontrar
solución hay soluciones con las harinas
que son locales por lo tanto ellos no se
benefician de estos costos y eso nos
permite tener precios fijos para el año
eso es lo que me explicó el molinero
además no sólo tenemos harinas
ecológicas sino también muchas harinas
pero de agricultura sostenible y sujetas
a la córnea
a finales de año el precio promedio de
una baguette en francia podría pasar de
85 céntimos a un euro
se estima que cada año se consumen más
de 10.000 millones de baguettes en todo
el país con el aumento en los precios de
la harina de la energía y del gas el pan
podría tener el aumento de presión más
importante de los últimos 20 años el pan
se hace cada vez menos asequible en esta
panadería parisina una baguette ya
cuesta un euro 10 un precio superior a
la media nacional que los clientes están
dispuestos a pagar
siempre hará el esfuerzo de comprar pan
de calidad para bloquear y sigue siendo
un gasto que me puedo permitir en
default curso de soporte pero hasta
cuando aquí como en toda francia el
precio de las baguettes no ha dejado de
subir al igual que otros productos de
consumo en 30 años a sodio un promedio
de 53 a 90 centavos de euro y este
aumento podría acelerarse el precio de
las materias primas utilizadas por los
panaderos
el precio de este costal va a subir unos
tres euros lo que representa un 15 20
por ciento del producto
y
los precios de los cereales se disparan
debido a la mala cosecha en rusia uno de
los graneros del mundo vio caer su
producción debido a las condiciones
climáticas de este año como resultado el
costo mundial del trigo ha subido más de
30 por ciento así que en lugar de
aumentar el precio de sus baguettes
freddy krueger prefirió subir el precio
de otros productos
por mi parte voy a aumentar mis panes
especiales porque además de la área
están los cereales el costo de la
energía que también aumenta
[Música]
esta es la otra explicación que dan los
paraderos para justificar el aumento del
precio del pan gastos cada vez más
elevados
este año hemos visto cómo se disparó el
precio de la electricidad los salarios y
los empaques de hecho todo ha aumentado
en términos de los gastos de la
panadería
según la federación del sector cada año
si eran mil panaderías en francia
se acerca la temporada navideña y los
niños comienzan a cero su lista de
regalos a papá noel sin embargo es
posible que las fiestas de fin de año se
vean impactadas por las interrupciones
de la cadena de suministro a nivel
mundial las jugueterías en francia
podrían no ser la excepción más sabiendo
que el 60% de los productos que estás
venden son fabricados en asia
estantes llenos en las jugueterías de
parís dan la impresión de que todo está
listo para la navidad pero todavía no
hay suficientes juguetes para satisfacer
la demanda
los distribuidores se apresuran a llevar
más mercancía de los buques de carga a
los almacenes y a las tiendas de todo el
país
no todo el mundo lo logrará este
fabricante chino de juguetes todavía no
puede enviar algunos de sus pedidos a
europa y eeuu
se suponía que todas estas cajas se
enviarían en agosto pero la entrega
tiene un retraso de dos meses
la escasez de contenedores y alquilar un
contenedor de 12 metros ha hecho subir
sus precios
aproximadamente el 20 por ciento de los
distribuidores de juguetes que planeaban
vender durante la navidad todavía están
bloqueados en asia
por lo tanto cada envío que llegue debe
enviárselo más fácilmente posible a las
tiendas
cada contenedor es una batalla en los
próximos dos meses estaremos descargando
de 30 a 40 contenedores por semana
aunque se espera que los precios suban
esta cadena de juguetes cree que el
aumento podría limitarse a
aproximadamente un 3% en comparación con
el año pasado
ante una posible escasez de juguetes
algunos padres de familia han optado por
comprar los de segunda mano aquí en
francia hay un sitio internet que los
vende y desde septiembre ha duplicado
sus ventas
tribu tiene cinco años y dos pasiones
las jirafas y los autos
a nutrición
y si algunos están un poco estropeado no
es culpa suya es que ya fueron usados
porque casi todos estos juguetes son de
segunda mano
ya no te molesta que otros niños ya
hayan jugado con ellos
su madre compra sobre todo de segunda
mano en una página especializada en
artículos infantiles
para ella la primera ventaja es el
precio encontramos un lote de 12 autos
por 12 euros en las tiendas por un auto
pequeño como este él pagaría 12 euros
12.50
incluso se dejó tentar por artículos
defectuosos como este peluche musical
creo que por éste pague en menos de
cuatro euros que ya me suena
creo que nueva debe costar alrededor de
40 euros sé que no funcionaba porque me
enteré cuando la compré y me balas pero
lo importante era llenar la colección de
tribus así que compré la jirafa
esta aplicación entre particulares ha
visto disparada su actividad en las
últimas semanas con más de un 54% de
ventas de juguetes este mes una señal
según su fundador de que este año papá
noel a apostar a por los juguetes de
segunda mano hoy en día la segunda mano
es más que sólo una alternativa a la que
uno recurre cuando no encuentra nuevo lo
que está buscando se está convirtiendo
en la primera opción para cada vez más
padres la página pone en contacto a
padres que compran y venden pero los
juguetes nunca pasan por sus manos a
diferencia a esta tienda que es
gestionada por una asociación los
juguetes que se encuentran aquí se
revisan y se reacondicionan antes de ser
puestos en las estanterías
-internet fayed ustedes todo fue
limpiado se verificó que todo estuviera
realmente limpio revisado según las
normas europeas y que funcionara con
julio en domingo pero cuando era pequeña
etiqueta verde significa que fue probado
controlado que funciona el que tiene
pilas en cuanto a los precios un
descuento mínimo del 50 por ciento en
los artículos nuevos y hasta el 90 por
ciento en los ligeramente usados tiendas
abiertas a todos sin importar sus
recursos
hasta aquí esta edición de francia
gracias por habernos acompañado
continúen con nuestra programación de
france 24 y france 24 puntocom